all right Brandon is with us in Ohio hi
Brandon how are you I'm doing pretty
good good for taking my call how can I
help
um I am 19 and recently got kicked out
of the house I am Journal fresh and
living with a friend and I always had a
vision to go to college and I want to
become an accountant but right now since
I have no car I have no I just started
my job I want to get out of my friend's
house I don't know if I should wait a
while should I go to college we gotta at
that point okay
why'd you get kicked out of your house I
wrecked my dad's truck it was money I'm
not the best with money but the last
thing that happened was I wrecked my
dad's truck after he bought it two weeks
since I was trying I work 70 hours and
six days and couldn't do it
driving home okay so you're working your
butt off and you wrecked his truck did
you have permission to be on this truck
yes I did he had no problem me drive
this truck to work it was it was just
temporary until my car got fixed but
after I reacted he took my car and
kicked me out so I just got another job
since I had to move away mmm okay so
what are you making now um twelve
dollars a little over but yeah I mean
you get coming hours of getting about 40
okay we need more than that coming in
yeah have you got any money at all no
okay
all right well your first goal is food
your second goal is to help your friend
a little bit with rent and then your
next goal is to get a car as quickly as
you can and really what you're looking
for here is a 500 or a thousand dollar
car something that you can save up and
pay cash for that's just a real beater
and when you're buying something like
that Brandon I call them garage sale
cars because that's where they sell them
is at a garage sale and what you're
looking for something is something
that's very ugly but
very good mechanically you see what I'm
saying yeah and so like a friend of mine
had a car he called a big red big red
was a 1994 Granada land yacht right it
wasn't me but if I'm worried yeah he
paid five hundred bucks for it and it
wasn't red anymore it was more like pink
because it had faded and the paint was
chipping and the vinyl dashboard was
split and the vinyl seats were split but
the car listen to this
the car had 21,000 actual miles on it it
was his great it was his great aunt's
car and it sat in her garage and rotted
basically and had no miles so that means
the motor and transmission were almost
new the brakes were almost new but they
were very old you know what I'm saying
right yeah he paid 500 bucks for big red
that's what you're looking for is
something that looks bad but has
wonderful lots of mechanics because you
need to get some miles out of the thing
so you can work like six jobs and save
up like crazy so our first the goal is
food second goals rent third goals get
you some little bit of transportation
and then the next goal is move up in the
transportation a little bit further up
into a few thousand dollar car next
goals get your own place and get get
stabilized and get enough hours and get
enough work coming because you're not
afraid of work you were working 70 hours
right yeah let's get all of that going
and get stabilized before we talk about
heading off to school right now you know
our place live or anything to drive
schools like late there's a little bit
further down the list all right is that
logical to you yep
okay ma'am if you need some help as
you're walking if you need some more
help as you're walking through this you
call me back I'll walk with you
I'll help you through this hey you guys
Rachael Cruz here hope you are enjoying
the Dave Ramsey show and did you know
that I have my
my own youtube channel yes that's right
kind of better than the Dave Ramsey
channel don't tell them I said that
I'm kidding I'm kidding so subscribe and
there's lots of videos about life and
money so while you're at it if you want
to check out a video then you can check
out how to do a monthly budget it's one
of the best videos out there
you